you threw the first pitch at a Mets game  this is last week and I've never done  anything like that and I have to say I  just saw a still of you pitching a  photograph of you pitching and it looked  like you had the right form and the  intensity there you are that's the  actual correct form you're getting on  that case I'm surprised back my arm what  I know you look like a very angry blind  guy I don't know actually to a strike  which I wanted them to show the video of  that but apparently your staff felt it  was more amusing to show me in my silly  glasses mid motion I'm guessing there  may have been yeah  also I'm guessing there were may have  been some money involved in us showing  the clip and we're not gonna spend money  on that [ __ ]  you